that's good you good you go down that
was my least favorite thing you good dog
okay I'm good you good yeah you good you
good
I'm at so much more that's four that's
five seven seven good we talked about
some of our friends before we got near
that certain low rise when they're
around black guys yeah
even even with black comics when they
get around in like damn dog like yo
we're bathroom up in this [ __ ]
yo hey I'm like dude I'm you're from
Orange County why I've never heard you
talk like it's a strange human beings
are social creatures
right so they don't tend to do that like
my father my father my father will we
have of this guy he was the head of the
Red Cross the International Red Cross
Swiss guy his name was Peary okay really
classy man like one of those guys just
read everything just and he's you know
it's I'm gonna try I can't even do his
accent is a bit more um like he's from
Germany or something like that you know
it suck and and he always ends his
sentences with yeah so you know we're
we're there yeah and we are and next
thing I know you're dead gone next thing
I know my dad's going well you went you
went you went to the you were on the
mountain yes yeah my sister hey dude my
sister help it sometimes this is like
hey with the yeah at the end of every
sense yes thank you
you this is my favorite too my father
goes I was in Hawaii for a while ah
banished I hate that but when we went to
Chile hey my dad to try that Italian
restaurants or even Mexican restaurants
give that get that dealer ah I know
you're from demo or sir why'd you say
Casa della oh this is the bass the guy
goes this is a left bank border sir now
left bank right bank you better know
your [ __ ] wines and shut up anyway
don't tell me about left bank aroma I
mean I've never met one guy who knows
who actually could taste it and goes
this is this is a right bank Bordeaux I
was like what yeah my father the guy
goes this is a left bank borders my
father left bank good I went hey hey go
pause like you were thinking about
whether or not we should change the
right now you don't know right yes
you've never heard that a fake it though
with scotland exmoor would you say you
don't want to be that
exact dude we haven't been in here since
uh Chicago
I want to thank you we took your little
I want to thank you she had a little
break and I'll be honest with you a
Thursday when you brought me out I got a
little money no so I had to I had to run
out before I started crying Oh cuz I
couldn't go out there I'll cry I'm doin
but I was like I felt like we'd come a
long way he hid announcement right it
was a legit announcement I had to walk
out because I was I was gonna [ __ ]
lose I wasn't keep going I know I got
choked up too so once I kill your voice
broke from me I'm like no you [ __ ]
what it was such a beautiful weekend and
and I have to say my last show I
captured everything I wanted yeah you
know cuz you work for to our to your two
and a half years on something you got
two hours to capture it some date nights
you know how it is you have an off night
or your fortune and the first hit out
the part I did they get the second show
I got it I thought your first show was
good it was great it was great but the
second show I hit those own and lately I
feel like you need purple that's why I
have horse too much right because when
you're doing full weekend you know it is
that first show they're good with the so
if you're there on a Friday night the
first two shows good Saturday night that
first and then the second your money all
right man that's where was well it's
just it's just being comfortable in your
marks you were crushing it you were
[ __ ] crush now I mean my parents my
parents I was so embarrassed
well I forgot your parents were there
about my kids dude he's dude don't bring
seven-year-olds I'm doing whole coding
dick jokes doing The Hulk Hogan sex tape
thing which is [ __ ] hilarious
the crowds dying but meanwhile my my
ten-year-old daughter and my
six-year-old son and my wife was like
covering their ears but you know what
they never mentioned it they never
mentioned it dude my father was like
when you're dead I'll [ __ ] get him out
of here when your dad came in the back
of them oh man I forgot you guys are in
the crowd I always forget my parents
said my parents they they remember they
were been on this journey with me for 23
years this done and they know something
about stannum because they know how hard
it is they've seen had long talks about
could stand up again we always say this
stand up like guitar like piano I mean
it takes a long time for some really
good at it
and my father my mother both said he's
really talented he was making all of us
laugh and and my mother said what is his
training before that I go he's never had
training before that I had trained with
he's been doing he's been podcasting and
you know he's got that blissful he's a
maniac
and he keeps working at it but they
loved it man but the audience loved it
okay so embarrassed you were laughing so
hard I know do you aware of it Oh what
when I can't but it didn't hit me until
they came in the back of the green light
oh [ __ ] I was talking about sucking tape
and [ __ ] yeah I was great it's great
time the guy that old guy was like he
was an older guy with a bald head
remember the guy was with my dad he I
think he was this oh yeah oh I believe
he was this used to be the CEO of a bank
of America like he was he ran the
biggest bank in the world
well didn't matter that they liked it
yeah they loved that show it's they
loved it so really you gonna get that
yeah they're they're usually the
dirtiest I finally old people are
actually dirty but also you forget like
it like when I do my set in front of my
dad I was kinda like oh god or my mom my
god [ __ ] you forget though they were our
age and they were [ __ ] 20 they were
in call it's like in the disaster new
toy that you got 700 800 900 people
standing up and screaming for you yeah
like they saw that too yeah you know
what I mean yeah so it was good
Chicago's it's not about me brothers
Chicago was great though no it was
amazing dude Gibson's did you know
that's like a world famous place sure
did you did and I ate there me too yeah
the the [ __ ] filet the sliders
outstanding the eye and I told chin this
on blowed up yeah that is the best thing
to ever hit my mouth Oh for reals is the
best thing they ever hit my mouth
hands-down
yeah well we were there and a rod and
JLo were there how good did Jo look she
couldn't look better at 49 she just is
her birthdays today she defies gravity
dude and and a rod is such a nice guy
man saying hi to everybody no you don't
by the way people lining up trying to
take pictures while they eat in and now
now afterwards and and nobody looking at
JLo JLo on the sideline no way not
kidding no
[ __ ] you look at her look at her look it
he rode with the powerful dad pod he's
got a powerful that [ __ ] given tits out
bro yeah do you want know how to get to
that level I love them too people hate
on for the steroids family shut the [ __ ]
up with a duty look at JLo god she's
amazing there's more pictures there
she's always been a freak my look come
on just three or four kids you know I
don't in jail let's not make that face
though let that more fun well I never
turns it off she's aware of the camera
no she turned off in the upper one seat
look my boy hey rod turn it off
Suns in his eyes tits squished to the
side a man give a [ __ ] how about how
about that picture you posted of Tom
Brady I said here's your grades
correcting fault unbelievable hashtag Oh
hashtag the biggest dick energy energy
he's about as muscular as Leonardo
DiCaprio they have the same body he and
Leo look at that and he works out
constantly
he works out cause did you see the doc
on him on Facebook she he looks like he
literally works out non-stop his wife is
like I hope he retires cuz this one
works out non-stop and he was like he
looks all is all I care about
she looks like his mom and he's an
overgrown uh twelve year old who was in
a bad mood and he's been told to take a
timeout cuz he's been beating up all the
other kids cuz he's taller variable yeah
it's like a c-section underneath his
belly I don't know what's going on there
bro appendix I think oh yeah might be
appendix either way it's not a bad body
it's not a bad thing best quarterback of
all time yeah uh you know what but but
what what's [ __ ] joe Montana's body
looked like do we know with the shirt
off uh Montana was a little essay on
Montana was pretty caught bring up Joe
Montana
Joe what that was better than that but
Terry Bradshaw was I've never seen him
in a he's shredded yeah Joe Montana well
that when you see their breath what do
you wanna Montana had a body you know
you can type in uh yeah there you go
dunking basketballs everything else yeah
but that doesn't matter uh guys don't
basketball sounds not good Doug gut yeah
Troy Aikman big muscular you know Dan
Marino not exactly gonna win that mr.
Olympia ether no that's what people to
understand it
complete like the like I'm Mara shocked
when I get to the NFL rock locker room
I'm Division one college locker room and
I was looking around like I thought
everyone would look like LeBron James I
thought literally everyone's like that
that's not the case it's just not the
way it works
Leigha fatal are one of the greatest
fighters athletes of all time he looks
like [ __ ] yep he looks like [ __ ]
polysemy [ __ ] fast [ __ ] Charles Barkley
was when he was 300 pounds really
overweight was dunking out of the gym
they saw Charles Barkley should be
skinny though so did Shaq like they were
tight there well he's just fat but even
before like a collie played for Hughes
no one even called you some skank when
he was on the rocket suit and sons he
was pretty skin there is for the six or
so yeah yeah he looks great he looks
great
that's a giant man they're huge
basketball players you know when they
when they retire and they're that big we
get a shape it's like oh my god oh
there's a one athlete whether you cannot
hide it yeah work with Nick Young that's
a good body right there work with Nick
Young really good yesterday and he he
he's very skinny very thin very sick see
ya then yeah but they're huge yeah
people realize how big those basketball
players are t seem like holy he's kind
of like John Jones like oh yeah yeah and
and then you go you go you're your he's
a [ __ ] nice guy did you are and love
how I celebrate him Nick Young is a good
guy man no unless your ears girlfriend
but did you um did you ask him about
biggie
these are ass real we didn't talk about
that didn't mention no is he's still
hitting it no not it I'm not up on that
stuff
well okay I don't want to be the guy who
throws questions sorry there's a few
things I think we're gonna stop staring
at your lip I think are another thing is
don't say is he's still hitting that
black guys Nick Young you still not done
well okay I think your ass is real and I
want aside this no you're nice and it's
not no can I tell you why I think it's
real
no look at her hips in her leg i critter
as a [ __ ] on her no no dude I'm an
expert I am an ass yeah that thing I do
not think is real I believe it is type
in her ass
chin I believe she harasses huh I'm
telling it's not it's about as real as
it is it's as real as Kim Kardashian's
hmm that looks a it's real interesting
that's a diaper bro that's a dumper
dumper yeah oh wait look at this
that looks really you think I think that
might be know what they do be what they
do is they get fat injections into the
ass so they're not implants it's just
inject isn't that but but I don't I
celebrate that's gotta be photoshopped
that weird no no no you ever seen Kim K
where it's not Photoshop just you know
what we even even went in TMZ and lets
up a lot of it's photoshopped
really goddamn well looks good of course
it looks good that's a professional
photographer yeah but look we go that
one when she's on the [ __ ] UH
where she's on the paddleboard I mean
that looks like a real photo that's
those are real guys those are coming
through they can't you they just get
adipose tissue stuff there so is that
why I can't talk yeah that's why it
almost looks like like you go to Kim K
pit but diaper but that's terrible don't
do the Tim kid diaper well just give Kim
K if you know it's gonna look like that
why do you do that don't do that then
I'm not mad at it
oh jeez like look at that that can't be
comfortable stop it that is my dick when
a sniff is that really true though I
feel like that's a lie do you like
that's being right or not Ryan look at
me yeah I I work for you I'm positive
for a lot of things yeah yeah this is
true but that's a disaster is it I just
kind of dig in French we say sailing
disaster look at how skinny her legs are
yeah bro you do that that acid you don't
mind you don't mind that it's all fake
adipose tissue or whatever it is you
know people like your tits or ass man
both well it's 19 both like faced its
wrath yeah well all three piltan both
but I want I want I want the real thing
those look like toothpicks hanging off
of watermelon yeah however strings
hanging from them from
watermelons I'm not mad at it though
like I wouldn't be like dude like maybe
take a little bit off the table but I'm
happy with the with her hip to waist
ratio that that's where my I wear my I
goes cuz man Kylie has the same [ __ ]
though
kylie is oh my god that is a dumper
trucker that's a dumper truck so she's
getting things shot in her body
yeah they put they get fat like
injections they can take belly or they
can just buy it from someone put it in I
don't approve it's called a Brazilian
butt lift
so this is very common I'm still so
naive to this stuff there's there's a
sim plants which are super tricky
because it's a tricky area to do and
then there's fat injections how did that
guy get that job
how would he he's definitely a gay man
yeah clearly such thing so it's not a
big deal for him but I'm just saying
that beer on yeah what you sweat oh come
on no with that ass that thing's going
huh oh no way the she's a very
attractive woman I have no issues with
it I agree I don't know why people are
late on cornrows like that yo dude only
called braids or corn cornrows
yeah but if Kylie Jenner has the same
[ __ ] though Nicki Minaj's ass is so I
mean have you ever seen her in person uh
a lot like like Kim and Nick either of
they're very short stumpy a lot of
people thick yeah yeah and she's had her
share of uh she's got a lot of fat
injections again might be a little much
for me you know I'm a little too
lighting yeah even I am too lighting
they ask for that yeah I feel like you
have to have a Nick Young dick to reach
things I know your dude you don't put
him down I get way I get you gotta have
you have the old steak route get in
there
you gotta have a Nick Young yeah yeah
yeah yeah you like like uh no bazookas
not gonna work in that now you got you
gotta have the snake route you gotta
have a serious you know when the plumber
gets the snake think like shoots their
two hands two hands with plenty of room
you don't try to say it you need to you
need a fire hose that's right now I'm
dealing with a [ __ ] you need the kind
of dick that looks like it's got lungs
and it breathes that's what you need
yeah but you need lots of lots of y'all
as Jeff Ross said you got you gotta have
a dick that looks like it's got a tonne
elbow yeah I kind of I mean yeah
surprisingly not a lot of actual real
shots like dumper ones like just her and
out in the beach or whatever I'd like to
have a dick that was simply too big so I
could go like this sorry about this well
they say you know they say that about
the type in Phoenix Suns I think is last
names Booker the girl it's just like the
doctor they say it's too big no one
wants to [ __ ] with uh-huh
Phoenix Suns Booker that's him right
there that guy Devin Booker is
reportedly supposed to have literally
the biggest dick in the regulations
really dad so look at that picture
that's biggest dick energy that's Mays
big dick MBA n really he looks something
an imagined in the NBA locker room yeah
it's big dick energy everywhere of
course I know one book or watch everyone
goes yeah he looks Samoan white black
he's a mix of everything the apparent
says the Kraken in his pain that's
incredible congratulations no I don't
know if there's a dick pic out there
what but the word around the room I call
the the part well the hard word horse
yeah the hard word horse you ain't
saying that well so I did a photo shoot
in Maryland and remember these running
backs with the tubs just put it in
Booker dick and you see what comes up
I'll put his first name T right Devon
Booker chick shot right there
so well that's him that's him chillin
bro that's in relaxed mode that's a
peace man that's lazy boy that's lazy
boy tell my buddy was that's late well
not no no no mm-hmm not like this
who was the guy Tubbs with the guy on
the Ravens was it Tubbs oh yeah yeah
tug trail Suggs Terrell Suggs yes large
man we gonna do with Jane Lynch and and
everybody else we're going to do a photo
shoot he's huge with this photo with
this photo guy there he is that guy so
there's a photographer he's like a white
guy and he's in his you know early 40s
and he's kind of a veteran been taking
lots of pictures taking pictures of me
Jane Lynch
the whole cast and he it was such a
weird thing cuz were there and he goes
um and he's in he goes I go I don't
think that's good man he goes I know I'm
not good actually he's shaken I go I'm
not I'm not gonna go I goes dude III and
they're already known people running us
dude I know I saw you know Terrell Suggs
and I go yeah the place for the Ravens
because yeah he goes he goes defensively
I saw his dick and I go then he said I
got them up bro I go I go he's no no
dude he goes and men never got hey goes
it was he it was traumatizing Lee large
and I go you're me I mean like it well
you know when I win a [ __ ] cheetah
sees a gazelle my ears are pricked I go
what did you say what's that
complete let's talk about this it's like
so instead fresh-baked cookies uh-huh
yep yeah you want some Toll House
cookies uh so I go um I go well I said
that dub dub Davidoff joke why the gay
guys always look like this just smelled
cookies yeah so many big cookies now man
you gay yeah yeah apparently I added my
cousin at Thanksgiving you know he was
like you took the last leg I was like
you're gay but he goes he has a
traumatising Lee large dick and I go all
right he goes no I saw it was he was
naked and I go you're taking pictures
because he a change in front of me and I
think he knew what he was doing I go oh
and he goes no dude I don't know so
should go do D and he goes hear that
PTSD D I never get this it was like this
weird studio he goes over and grabs a
paint can a spray pink and he goes okay
see this he goes three times the size do
you know the long ones and I go I do now
because that's what it was like soft he
could that he kept dangling it but you
know someone so much summer showers and
then others are grown that's what we
think I'm tired I've seen it I've seen a
lot of porns man it's like you know that
things I see it's obscene harm guys ya
know yet Terrell Sykes having a monster
dick is nothing I think that I mean when
you look at him it's not like but but
every book I feel like is a surprising
he's a bit of a surprise looks like nice
kid and then you get home and it's
[ __ ] here you 50 shades of [ __ ] tank
was a girl I had sex with a guy in the
MA like that and she said click on that
Leisha and she's apparently Devin Booker
I said what was it like and the girl
goes it was like having a third person
in bed with us
I mean by the way as it says it says the
title says word is Devin Booker of the
Sun says a serious knee banger '[ __ ] we
got the dick report although by the way
you're not getting much bigger than that
things 14 inches and his thick as Poland
in the spring as thick as Poland in the
spring he worked on this girl said this
a few months he was in my DMZ finally
connected when it came to name that the
cities retracted he warned me that he
was big before we get back to his room
but I had no idea that thing is 14
inches this thickest Poland Spring we
tried to put in but couldn't fit not my
mouth not my [ __ ] nowhere I felt so bad
I ended up using my hand you see him in
a British by the size normally I would
say a big dick is a blessing but in his
case it's a curse and that's like word
around town like it's just girls like
now what are we gonna do he's on the
opposite end of the spectrum we just
have like two girls just one hand and
like you just can't see Jen firehose
it's like alright well I know it sucks
right pork cuts up that should be a
picture of him from her ghonte look at
that thing like that's that that's that
bigfoot sha bro yeah that's great
it doesn't the game have a dick like
that basically I'm not like that game
has a flat fat hog but that's crazy hog
yeah I don't know how I started on big
dicks bro well the big guys as I've got
many many emails from veterans and
military don't ever stop talking about
dicks what's up my friends and I talk so
yeah well yeah yeah there's a new
there's a new big dick energy first team
didn't you tell me that somebody was
like he's got that podcast when they
talk about elves in Lion bro the guy
goes I don't know him yeah you know I
mean thing is that I used to talk about
dicks all the time like what dude
there's a lot of people in here manly
big time with Brian and Brendan but pipe
down bro but pipe the [ __ ] down a pipe
down man
pipe down so you taking a little break
from the road now you shut your special
taking a break I've thought about
standing how long asking us to do my
show tonight just kidding now how long
do they think it's gonna take they're
already cut really soon so try and get
out a couple months yeah
like it's two months start should
they'll start shopping around they
already sent me some a rough version of
things I'm really yeah our boy Matt got
some great pics right this picture we're
good ice em do you boy that's great
Amanda he's great what's his last name I
don't mess it up he goes by multi Mars
on multi Mars yeah Jack Multi Mars he's
got to such a beast
yeah love those shots he's my guy he is
the funniest pictures there is he works
with there's Matt and Mars all he
working our team so he worked with Rick
Ross and then he's Gucci Mane's personal
photographer and he's shown this picture
of a Rick Ross party and it looks like a
vanilla blueberry surrounded by a sea of
blueberries it's just one white
blueberry and then it's a pool party and
he's in the middle he's funny he's the
only white guy
allowed in there you know who is that
crazy guy didn't he die that poor kid no
that kid well pump little pump he's big
right now look at this Louie Vuitton
[ __ ] fit a little pop bluesy face
yeah that's not a thing to do these days
miss Brennan
yeah he's a beast man little pop little
pump so you can take a break now dude
huh yeah yeah if I was a rapper I'd call
myself medium white
I'll tell you spots spots to be good
what's up spots little spots spots are
getting way better what is it let me see
cuz your lips look terrible in her oh
[ __ ] wait wait wait thank you damn girl
it's like almost gone what do you do uh
he's just working my gut you got to earn
some medication though ya know it's what
he's giving me its supplements but
it's--but
he said though the damn garner is this
sandy Galpin put me in today's a
strengthen the nutrition girls been a
certified nutritionist but like he's got
his functional medicine degree and
everything else he's a [ __ ] badass and
I did Aubrey put me together with this
guy named Mahmoud
Ghanim who is the guy who coined the
term that gut biome like he studies all
the bacteria in the gut he's like a
leading scientist in this new science
the [ __ ] guy
I did a they took six weeks analysis of
my gut like all the bacteria dan Garner
was everything everything he recommended
to submit doodoo yeah everything this
guy everything this guy recommended to
me Dan Garner already had recommended I
go how the [ __ ] did you know he goes
dude I'm I'm a I'm a maniac all I do is
sit and think about this [ __ ] and I'll
it was so completely been doing he's got
me on a probiotic protocol and then you
have certain bacteria in your stomach
that are opportunistic bacteria that
shouldn't be there some all of us have
it but some people just react
differently to it and so you take
certain microbe you know you take
certain kind of like supplements that
help to kill that bacteria and for
Holland you have to take this up only 30
days and then it's already gone but but
then you do a probiotic protocol there's
a way to do it there's a step-by-step
where there's no way yeah and so I'll be
done with that buy-in by October 24th
damn yeah it's [ __ ] amazing so you
should be good yeah already it's crazy
yeah I'm impressed you can still drink
alcohol don't tell me to I'm not now cuz
I'm just trying to show my thing yeah
you know I've been doing I've been
jealous and Jordan Peterson talked about
it I've heard a lot of people talk about
I've been doing Kido for a while but the
dairy with the kita I just I'm gonna I
just don't feel great on dare I can [ __ ]
with almond milk like the cheese and the
heavy creams all that I don't feel good
so then I heard Jordan Peterson news
might be the smartest man in the world
talk about his carnivore diet
I mean Rogow time I don't like [ __ ] I'll
give it a go so since I got back from
Chicago which is Saturday I've been all
carnivore diet problem with that is that
it's not sustainable ultimately it's a
die yeah I hear that [ __ ] also also they
find that a lot of available science is
and even Jordan Peterson said look this
works for me and it does it for certain
so when I say what died on
I'm not saying Brian this is good for
you I know Jen this is good for you this
is what I'm doing right but come on hold
on this is what I'm doing this what
works for me you know I'm saying so I
can't tell you my people go that's not
sustainable it I'm asking for that I
don't tell you about diets because I
want your input on it yeah well I'm
saying what this is what works from have
tried it for four days yeah it's gonna
be great yeah now is it can I do it for
the rest of my life absolutely not
exactly no I mean that's a good point
too everybody's different and you
ultimately will need some fiber and you
need vegetables or not I know people
that don't well you know it's true that
the bond to belty entire bunch of bells
in Africa and certain like Somalia the
Sudan a lot of those nomadic tribes
essentially live on or did live on its
high fat milk and blood I mean they
would drink their animals blood came up
the Mongols were essentially Mongol I
mean complete carnivores yeah but but
it's so so it depending it is true that
you can get you know I get the Native
Americans there are a lot of tribes that
were strictly carnivorous sure I don't
know the answer but am i light-headed
yes yes I am well you've always been
moderate I mean you'll try things and
then yeah it's pretty easy to stick dude
I listen I think if I actually listen to
you because I think you're the most
level-headed about diet because you
always say a couple things one
moderation doesn't work for you great
how do you feel second of all there's a
difference between being a high
functioning athlete and what you need
versus being a regular lifestyle guy did
you know depending what your body moves
there you go and sometimes it
good to just dude shake it up and do
something different I I for sure think
that keto diet is probably the best way
to lose weight a lot of then there's a
scientific reason for that any listen
anyone who's does any diet you're on I
can find medical research that opposes
it yeah so I do not care what diet
you're on what you takin I promise you
and find an article from a scientist
that says for study whatever you want
yeah how do you feel as far as the
lightheadedness I mean is there any do
you feel better awesome job on Sunday
because I didn't have any carbs at the
night I was a little lightheaded
you crave anything oh yeah especially at
night sugars all sorts tough when I've
been fine I mean do you feel good other
than lightheaded yeah I feel fine yes so
when you say carnivore you're eating all
kinds of meat just beef just beef just
red meat
not a cheap diet don't you've done no
you know I know eggs no nothing
nope just been the straight corn over
and you can't have like a lot of season
you can just have salt and beef and
right here haven't been crazy yeah
little backed up probably yeah cuz my
lows have been pinched off and cleaned
with my probiotic protocol oh that's
tough I love chatting well I think right
proba that's hinged off and clean I mean
I don't even need to flush the toilet
okay when you have a six-year-old get
used to this six-year-old forgets how to
wipe you know the others and just just
there's [ __ ] everywhere I come and I go
with their [ __ ] I love you always I
don't do well with [ __ ] did you paint
did you finger paint with all the [ __ ] I
feel freaking [ __ ] out dag dad would you
guys do the last day in Chicago though
um I got drunk on the most expensive
wine in the world with your boy with
with Joey enjoy that I was with my
mother my father my wife my two kids
just stayed at Thompson and I had such a
good time we went to this amazing
restaurant and I had such a deep feeling
of satisfaction and I dress and Joey
goes he goes
gay I chose this restaurant for their
wine list
get a real wine this is a celebration I
go alright I love that guy I know he's
great is that [ __ ]
Joe and that I'm known Joey since I was
18 years old young man and I go I'm a
hitman to kill both of them
yes he could he saw again he flies
privately he flies from London to
Chicago in his own jet he's cruising
with us and he goes out you guys get a
get a get a while I look at $188 wha
what is it
I said Brenham I don't do much you know
the thing is hey hey hey get a wine but
what did he bring backstage for us I was
no those were just those were just
whatever was the button oh he said it
was a three thousand dollar wine no he
thought it was they thought it was a
really expensive wine he's full of [ __ ]
he brought he brought two mm Margaux
which is what was really no we drank we
drank some expensive pen poles we drank
some smell I can't tell the difference
no he you know why there were young ones
he thought his eyes suck he thought it
was a 2010 it was a 2015 he goes oh my
god this is this just did not ready to
drink people like oh it's so it wasn't
ready to drink it wasn't it's good it
was all right $2,000 I don't I don't
know wine it all time that was that was
not gonna let me smooth theirs were
smooth
check this out that beer that they had
backstage you said it was the best right
who's a great great fruit I forgot the
name you like a little sweetness to your
beer yeah we looked it up though it
wasn't really sugar in there but that
was my last time Joey do you scolded me
and made me get some wines that well
that my house payments okay my house
payments all right what'd you pay for a
pair of Louie don't don't shoes we I got
drunk on that one
I started ringing and boy oh boy to the
waitstaff come alive
do they ever [ __ ] come alive when you
start off very wise they're like well my
chips gonna be but then there's some AAA
the guy come on over sir can I can I
recommend we have a very special one
here I'm like of course you do dude I
feel like people in Chicago it's so much
nicer than every other city Chicago is a
real City I mean Chicago has got I love
Chicago Brutes
I never appreciated that much like when
we landed I even said your boy jazak got
Chicago is alright to me I feel like
it's overrated then I was there for
those two days specially in the summer
like dude Chicago's [ __ ] great worst
traffic I've ever seen amazing in fact
you've ever seen you don't want to be
there in the winter because it'll hurt
your face winters terrible okay it'll
hurt your face
winners 252 colt I don't know Gibson's
was like a classic Steakhouse I heard uh
Glover Teixeira who's a nut clover
texture [ __ ] love whoever takes Texas
Tech sheriff for the Yankees longtime
Yankee he was talking they're asking
about his favorite cities to play ballin
and he goes in Chicago's like forth I
was top five he was Wrigley because I
need done with the game we're playing
the afternoon then I can head over to
Gibson to get steak yeah and then even
Greenberg was like yeah [ __ ] Gibson's
a hell of a steak it gives me god
Gibson's is good I had a big sweet
potato I want to go back out there man
and not work when they're Sayed right
across the street Tom Berg in September
I which is I would say the Thompson and
then drive into Chama how far you don't
want to be in staying shot but how far
is takes me 25 minutes so that's it I'll
do that traffic you have to give you
such a listen the stops like that
Schaumburg it's worth it stay at the
tops yeah because there's nothing in
Schaumburg right and I love being a
Chicago man and been stay do there's a
slider in my mouth as well you call that
the viagra triangle you know like that
area because all oh look the altar dudes
yeah Humbert you see some congressional
some professor now you see some
professionals looking for a meal ticket
okay and they just stroll around oh you
know what we didn't uh didn't grilled
the old chinch and it already I did oh
you did I got this no she's a kid
please I was like but she didn't ever
get you know the lady stay in his room
Jen yes sir I'm gonna tell you this lady
stays in my room she flies to [ __ ]
Gotham she wants to stay in the room she
ain't just doing it for deed the beef
sliders I'm taking that as a sign that
she wants the Korean kielbasa okay
now I know you have a problem with that
I think I'll paint the picture clear I
know that you prefer middle-aged men
that you can then just afterwards
between their blood and that's because
you're a serial killer five she wants
your was saw only polite to throw your
wasabi Korean wasabi tainted awful
wasabi Dom all right no what we're
trying to say chin is
you need to put your eel sauce in her
face that's that's that's Japanese
Japanese - gonna have to ask on this
podcast to stop conflating your sauce in
Chinese I feel sauces jeffires is you
conflating I was trying to paint the
picture clear for chin these are very
distinct cultures there on the history
sir okay let me see this
chin you need to drop your nuts and her
ramen noodles ramen noodles sounds gross
now ramen who is our Japanese - Japanese
black man Japanese she's not Japanese
she's from Africa okay well this is
Tufton now dude paint it clear last
year's election yeah yeah a little
afraid of the Africa
honey it's okay but look at me are you
afraid African punani you can talk to
Daddy I'm here nobody's listening no
one's listening I'm not afraid of it but
no she's not your style - homie my style
your style alright yes correct employers
it has a heartbeat it is I'm not I don't
I've seen some Inuit women and little
hard path this just Alsace I'm not gonna
share my seal jerky with there's a
thickness to the torso and then the
short limbed because I'm that's conserve
heat and their face that's not my type
the face takes up all the smells got a
cute they're cute hi are there beautiful
people but I just I have an in general
and I have an image of maybe I maybe I'm
being ignorant about this but if you go
all the way down sure Sonja senator you
need okay but whatever yeah but either
way you had fun in Chicago 10 there is
the best we're gonna release that
behind-the-scenes footage still working
on it hopefully by this week but there's
a lot of footage and stuff useful to not
not just the the shows Oh what else do
you
you do bro there's a bunch of stuff from
here in the studio when Mitrione is here
Swardson Mitrione yeah
god that's a while ago oh you're going
way back yeah it's just a big fat
episode so it'll be good and ends with
the show the chin cam Jen can use some
career events where's Jen yeah there's a
freaking ton eiope pretty hard go for it
you got a piss let me help you out let's
go did you want to talk about that guy
that attacked you Brian did Brian tell
you some crazy guy
um yeah I had an experience with Yosef
posing in Chicago I came down loved
Yosef and this we were sitting down
after my two shows we're at hi we're at
though downstairs there's a downstairs
area oh no I heard this really cool
downstairs borrowed that bar yeah
everyone yeah yeah went down there and
there was a young man who he had long
hair and a nose ring one of those bull
rings and his nose which has never
attracted and he smelled strong it's not
like a water buffalo he had he had a
blonde bob like a girl's haircut mm-hmm
he had very loose he was a just on oh I
was there and I had a very loose shirt
on and get in sandals okay he was like
can I talk to you and I was sitting down
I go what because can I please talk to
you and I go shooting I love you I love
you so much and he hugged me and I went
oh you smell so strong sir strong like
like like like the Parmesan cheese in a
car ooh like soup he smelled like bad
soup no they cometh yes and I went okay
somebody hasn't taken a shower but
that's okay very drunk and a little
drugged up I didn't know what to say but
he said I just love you and thank you
and I love you and I said well thank you
and you hug me again and I said thank
you might be a little money hug me again
okay there was a lot of hugging and
holding me and when you hug a man when
you press your your three-piece set
against the other man through he said
who were things give a gonzo know he was
conjuring up Oh
ronzo it went gonzo gonzo and went
burglar man yeah he wanted to be you
know when you you used that your bump
iPhones to exchange information he did
the same he I phoned me
maybe that's we found a new fist bump
dick heads with yes yes we gonzo nosed
and so I went okay and I broke away and
I'm at now I want you to watch I want
you to watch the Boogie Nights scene
with dad with Dirk Diggler
yeah all right here we go see Mark
Wahlberg in the situation in the
restaurant what you do that I'm so wait
I'm really wasted I'm really I'm crazy
crazy for dick do you like my car yeah
because I wanted to make sure you
thought it was cool or else I was gonna
take it back
alright this Mark Wahlberg's first like
big movie this what cinema so guys how
great stupid
give me after I bomb it so heartbreaking
he's beautiful man
how good is Philip Seymour Hoffman knows
how good I know what an actor and all of
us have felt that in one way or another
man he just loved him and he wanted to
kill me I'll try kissing a dude guy
rejected yeah I hear you
well we're all thought with girls wealth
is there anything we get shot down
especially when you have a crush on a
girl or do you like her or no do you
ever that's girlfriend sure had a dance
and they're like and you meet the
handless you oh no no or no but I'm
saying like prom or homecoming you were
you dancing oh no because they're not a
deal with your kids do so they're like
oh no I don't say I appreciate this like
no sorry my friend guys 19 you know in
college where and they they go they were
there in like Italy and on vacation with
their parents and they go this disco
these girls are so hot and they're going
up and ask them and dancing like what a
dancing girls are like No so my friend
just gets mad he goes yeah she's here's
what I dance to goes no thank you you
guys yeah I was gonna take a [ __ ] anyway
this Americans anger overcomes our
suspect because hey hey hey listen don't
be mad that's not how we do it here like
you can't just ask her all that she
doesn't know you
yeah and you're an American guy you're
coming out of like an American there's
and shadows dances were chin did you go
to homecoming prom prom only the once
senior year
yeah you have pictures from that right
idea are they on your Instagram no show
me I feel like you were that was like
like what would they come try and oh I
quote ventriloquist no transgender no
event restrict transgender youth
transgender that's the way I know look
at this yes I got it's very all the way
to [ __ ] Klein was uh what's that when
the girls ask you to dance to the Sadie
Hawkins dance
all right it's gonna take a while class
wait till you see this nothing I even
had a problem no that is so far down you
guys could talk about something else
well no I can't wait for this all up for
your prom dude yeah there it is there it
is look at this this looks right that's
you bro well that's your daughter that's
a doll that's a fake doll gonna a
haircut what a day yeah and you got a
you got a little doll on your chin I bet
you had so many friends who are girls
like you're the one okay your friend
Terry Lawrence what's up that's that
that's a dancer that's an interesting
look chin says drink it and my say
Hawkins day Jenni Jeff two different
high school so Mosby brought them no
idea who she was
that's it she was a puppet and I was a
talented Ben dude look at that who
thought you put to put you on hey and
have her sit on your lap everyone does
it when you line up maybe that is so
good you were so big you want to sit
down she's gonna sign your lap no
everyone did this but it was just when
you look at us together it just looks
ridiculous what did you guys dance that
night yeah she was my date for that I
know but a lot of dudes don't dance yeah
I danced a dance of Prompto and that was
a sweater vest yeah that was in and load
those are Jenko pants Oh Maggie gingka
huge so you look like the genie from
Aladdin Aladdin Aladdin bro did you look
like a giant Aladdin genie but would you
guys do after the dance like you dance
all clothes and you got that boner you
know what your dancehall clothes you
like and then you weren't allowed to put
your [ __ ] hands down on their ass and
the teacher come around and lift your
hands like what a cock-block bro they
never did that chin like we're allowed
to like go below the waist oh my god
hands up gentlemen yeah no trying to get
my rocks off son try to you just
navigate a tad right good man would you
guys do that did you do it did you no we
just our whole group went out to that
norms restaurant norms god I'm just a
no okay no kissing in the car nothing I
didn't kiss this I was like freaking in
my early 20s mmm there's a lot of time I
was a love chat with my girlfriend once
I was crazy about her in college like
kind of my first real sexual experience
and we were post-coital we had some good
sex and it's kind of a chordal I was
like rubbing it like Oh what turns you
on like she goes she goes strong hands
just big strong hands that's kind of
Rome your body's a big strong handshake
like a big muscular striation there I
was like wow this is over yeah yeah that
would be cool all right I'll see you
tomorrow I'm great big side oh yeah that
kind of ink there's no kernel man that's
just you with that so you didn't tell us
so what'd the guy do oh let me I mean
chime in here quick so what you showed
us that [ __ ] Boogie Nights yeah scene
so the guy's [ __ ] so the guy comes
back as a guy with the nose yeah I'm
talking to you if his microphone akka
and he just looks at me and he goes he
goes yeah he sits down he's trying to
get in on the conversation I'm like I'll
just ignore me though he's white he he
falls into a cross-legged set he was in
he just falls in and pushes his hair his
beautiful blonde little bob back he's
waiting in front of it just stands up
and he goes I need to talk to can you
just scoot scoot and I got no no
actually there's no room because there's
no room because can you just scoot and
he's trying to sit on my lap and finally
I said no I turn him back around and
then he looks at me and he goes huh and
he comes in to kiss me and you're set
just goes hey hey pushes the guy's face
away whoa whoa whoa whoa take it a give
me the copy whoa Jim I was like I
grabbed the guy go thank you thank you I
just can't talk right now and his girl
his friend took him away
then did you slimy a number and did you
take side
laughs no but I did I did bang him was
his fate with his blonde face in the
pillow Wow would you were there Jim
so you laughing dude no we were like I
feel like she was so drunk and Jim was
traumatized I feel like when what the
kitchen went oh yeah it was weird man it
was super worried it was very very
strange
it was very aggressive but he was so he
was not just drunk he was drugged some
he was sitting on the side active he was
sitting on the side sitting down like
Indian style by the table just staring
at Brian he was a young boy he's a young
man he was probably no 28 Playboy yeah
and I'm 51 yeah yeah it's over Fogg he
had a daddy complex
yeah he had daddy complex heaven forbid
that's a young attractive girl like why
how did that happen I just know yeah he
is married when I was when I was young I
come off stage and I had this Colombian
girl who just was so good-looking it's
so good-looking
and she goes you're so hot you're so hot
you're just so hot and she was looking
at me like she was lost professional she
was a law of sessional I know what daddy
paid the bill oh yeah and then I don't
want to be rude so you know pay the
bills yeah and then then I remember
later on she goes you know I'm pregnant
have you ever been this someone so badly
that you just want to drink their blood
oh wow and I went sure haven't miss
Vampira have a good night
have a good night how about on that I
was telling people about then I posted
it that showed the dark tourists I've
heard of this I saw it on your end you
watch it yes you see the vampires in New
Orleans I didn't see the bumpiness the
the host is hilarious to me that again
from New Zealand cuz he's some girls New
Orleans because it's not a hit man
there's a bunch of vampire there's a
vampire group in New Orleans and he's
like oh it's gonna be like the Twilight
that'll be sucked in blood and he gets
there and it's like a group that thinks
they're vampires they all live in a
house and they're they're not vampire
dwell they think they are they actually
keep these teeth implants so they've had
their sure they have fangs and [ __ ] sure
but then he gets the house things I
can't do what blood drinking tonight and
they got yeah this is this is basically
how I feast on air and it's like feces
like dampness can be sick man bees and
bite and there's be blood everything
it's like a young kid and they go into
the bathroom and he puts surgical gloves
on he goes oh I wasn't I wasn't aware of
vampires worried about hygiene where do
we go and then he takes a little razor
blade and just nicks the guy's back and
then sucks
weird he is well it's not really what
vampires do bro man he goes how do you
feel as I get my eyesight's bet like
King just tell this guy's full of [ __ ]
he's like my eyesight's better you know
I feel energized when I do this much
blood I mean think if you make my back
and sock off get the [ __ ] outta here
[ __ ] off but it's so Frankie's like I
definitely thought this we can go
different there's no nutritionist that
I'll tell you to drink someone else's
blood no no it's kind of a you know
that's come out few bathe in young men's
blood you look like JLo that's true
that's but you know that's coming you
know pretty soon it's like i'ma I drink
blood I drink I drink I'm a vampire I'm
on the vampire diet it works dude it
cleared up all my cancer it's good shows
[ __ ] brilliant though so I like that
guy seems staged that bad
no you don't watch it did you yeah did I
watch the that guy's an actor bro he
gets that guy it's playing a character
Pablo Escobar explain that that girl
yeah that's what he does this it's like
this is a little like I was watching
about this guy's obviously oh he drives
people around and gives him a tour yeah
Papa Papa is real yeah but not this guy
like this he looks identical Pablo
Escobar oh he's but he does a tour
around town driving me nuts like he's a
joke that's hilarious
I think it's funny because this guy
doesn't like you and pull punches like
do this is kind of [ __ ] like they go
on the the nut Ted Bundy who's the other
Jeffrey Dahmer tour and they're like do
act like they're talking to spirits he's
like this is [ __ ] man this is a
shame yeah and while I'm in dowse people
reach out to because in Dallas they have
the JFK assassination tour I won't go on
that I send out the second week of
August
I mean Jarrett Ron one thing you'll
notice that when you go up where he shot
JFK you'll see it's very there's an X
yeah but also it's it's much closer than
you think it's it's really interesting
the whole thing is that's one cancer
Souter I believe Oh
people are talking yes you talk about
how you know his head gets blown off and
she jumps out the back I'm like why the
[ __ ] once you get down they said what
she did is
pretty normal because this is some of
his head went towards back and she's
like oh [ __ ] he's gonna need that like
her her thought was I'm gonna grab this
and put it back that like she wasn't
trying to escape she's trying to collect
his brain matter in skull that's right
that's it I still don't my mother said
that's exactly don't believe that I
don't know that's what that's what he
talked about [ __ ] would she go back and
grab that I've seen the video so many
times nobody and she said and that's
what my mother said that's the
psychology you gotta listen to the to
the call to you when they break it down
she's literally she's grabbing up she's
like she had brain and skull matter all
over her and that she saw a big chunk
and she's like oh [ __ ] yeah like if if
me and counter [ __ ] driving his arm
youth blown off I see his arm like what
my reaction you have that [ __ ]
obvious I think that all why else would
she do that - I can jump out of the back
I think I thought she was she saw the
head explode well first he got shot
multiple times right so no no he got
shot in the throat yeah she was like
looking after I'm like oh my god I think
there were total of four shots was fine
but either way um I think that all of us
in that horrible situation have no idea
what we're gonna do and your instincts
take over they said her instinct was to
grab the back of his like is this brain
so let me explain what I think I think
she felt when she saw the head blown off
cuz that's totally understandable if he
sees with someone's head blown off you
know freaked out was to hit did it
remember it's part like his oh it's over
flopped over it flopped over I think she
panicky pieces because you know there's
more bullets coming so she's panicked to
get out of the car then there's brain
stuff on the car and then the guy Clint
Hill you know the Secret Service guy he
ran on top of the car and tells her go
back go back go back and she's just
freaking out she sees he's brain matter
really and then goes back in the car
that's what I think but I mean there's
so many different and different theories
on that who knows I still won't take
that tour anyone with a legit or tour in
Dallas let me know so he is shot shot in
the chest there in the throat online
she's like you know she didn't know what
she said she's alright so she she's like
oh [ __ ] I'm outta here that's what I
think
yeah and then the nosy security Secret
Service pushes her back in I think
honestly you're going like that and if
you're trying to climb over there's
gonna be brain matter it looks like
she's trying to gather it up though it
could be you know no I know right she
knows I don't know yeah no argument so
[ __ ] awful dude you can see like what
oh [ __ ] and then it goes oh it's [ __ ]
brutal anyways this is a terrible thing
but no one knows exactly what happened
yeah but that thing with the whole dark
tourist show what's interesting to me is
like I thought he'd be like a superfan
all this stuff the dark arts and all
that [ __ ] but he's like I find it
fascinating like a lot of Americans are
and that's all he goes all over even
Colombia with Paulo Pablo Escobar but
here goes people are like with the with
the Jeffrey Dahmer stuff he goes this
guy committed horrible murders and you
guys are capitalizing off what he did
it's like these tours or like with Jeff
cake it was a president died here and
you guys give tours and all this [ __ ]
and make money off that he was I find
this very strange that people celebrate
this now it's become like a hotspot it's
because its history I know that's why I
said I'm into it like I'm not into the
darkness I don't like that [ __ ] I think
I believe in this conspiracy theory it's
one of the only ones I do and the world
is awfully flat but the thing is is III
think it's very suspect that Jack Ruby
shot Lee Harvey Oswald well why would
that guy and he was tied to organized
crime the whole thing's like this
something's going yeah yeah yeah
something I believe that I'm not sure if
the government I think he's definitely
tied to something I think I think Shane
happened yeah he was also a playboy oh
man he did [ __ ] but he might be the
most [ __ ] out of any prints yeah he
was he was bad or good I've celebrated
had style too probably only president
was style what else you got Jim quick
Mme one's some announcements you do
watch gin then all the way I just picked
up from this I'm looking forward to
there's gonna be a test yeah Daren till
versus time would be for the
welterweight belt and Colby Covington
was stripped of his title silly as that
yeah it just makes him I'll why I was
called by Covington Strip there's no
real reason other than he didn't want to
take the fight because he's
he wants to post point so he just fought
right did five rounds and then he's like
I'll fight in october/november when you
guys want to do it and he's like how
long is Woodley been out he has a rush
me to fight like what are we doing she
went five rounds with RDA the brakes I
need a rest cuz he's havin surgery on a
sinus yeah it's minor surgery we still
haven't surgeries like I can't be ready
to go in with September this is this
September yeah sometimes I can't be
ready to go except sinus surgery I won't
be fully you know health 100% before I
fight Woodley nucleus welp sorry we're
stripping of your belt he's like what
the [ __ ] man it just makes a mockery of
the interim belts already we would make
fun of them but now if you're a fighter
so if you're Bryan are taking everyone's
like dude you should have fought for the
intern belt this is why you don't fight
for those belts this is the exact reason
why you do not fight for the belt yeah
cuz the the fans we know it's not real
yeah the UFC doesn't respect them right
so why would you step up and take the
chance of fighting anyone else then what
you're planning to fight so now Kobe
Cummington
is I do I fight November I nope have to
do it now or never it's like [ __ ] it and
I think this is a much much worse
matchup for Woodley it's a scary one
it's a bad matchup for Woodley yes but I
thought Kobe and Woodley that's a great
fighters there's history there's bad
blood it'd been a way bigger
pay-per-view for both of those gentlemen
and I think it's stylistically stylish
Lee it's a better fight for Woodley
would leaver still is a much different
mats have we seen till with a wrestler
of anywhere near the caliber of a
Woodley though know the interesting
because if you're Woodley
what do you want to do you want to take
them down but wood is very explosive but
you know I think with if you had your if
you had to think what would you do you
expect Woodley to stand and bang or do
you expect what they do use well you
can't really just wrestle these days
like it's 2018 so if he just goes in
there he's like oh I'm just gonna get
knocked the [ __ ] out yeah tills been you
don't you don't think Joe's been around
for a while man
and he's big he's huge yeah God the
other interesting thing too well this
time tills with my favorite fighters I'm
glad he got the title shot but all
so would here with fans are sick what
are we doing just shows you with us he's
at right now with logistics till miss
wait his last fighting miss wait and it
was a boring fight and then you reward
that with a title thing so now remember
missing weight was the number one thing
you couldn't do in the other day if you
did that you were back to the queue
I didn't know he lost weight I just know
miss wait Wow well he's missed weight
and then you had the Wonder Boy fight
which II was a conflict of styles so I
think if people are expecting this to be
similar to Woodley Wonder Boy you're so
mistakenly wrong till is not a Wonder
Boy he's not just gonna stay on his back
foot he's gonna pressure he's gonna
pressure Woodley really yeah no yeah
he's a monster and it comes straight out
here yeah yeah you stand up you know I
level like yeah I mean well obviously
Wonder Boy super super high level 2 but
Wonder Boys a counter striker till can
tells a pressure guy
the only he just didn't want to pressure
Thompson so you know it's a it's a it's
a it's a tough fight from Woodley man
yeah well he hasn't been active man so
there's not like would he turn this down
it's like [ __ ] until the until is also
got with his skill set if again it's
very interesting because to me for
Woodley it's his toughest matchup there
and for till it's his toughest matchup
but if till can pass this he's give me
champ for a while to rise all the tools
but also with the weight cut thing yeah
he's gonna make weight he's a huge 77
natural he's a light heavy you said he
was game it like he has a cheat code to
the system because he can make the
weight but then finally caught up the
guy caught older it's harder and harder
he's also stepping in the ring at 201 or
something huge man come on but I'm
excited for the fight but you know if
you're Kobe come to Fame you're like
what the [ __ ] man hmm business-wise it
doesn't make that much either this is
why rush until you know he there's other
big fights for him why rush till why you
know the beef between kholby and wood
leads exactly what Woodley needed to
kind of become more mainstream right and
but also if you're if you're gonna give
till the fight who's coming off well you
beat that moment down in the world so
it's a little different but
if you just want a big name fight Nate
Diaz if you're ever watching a so
everything caution the win why not offer
Nate Diaz a shitload of money to get
Woodleigh a big now there's that when is
this memory it's soon yeah what else yet
another one Paula Costa against you all
Romero for November third UFC 230 this
where you tell the Nowitzki take a hike
I know it's you
I know when they make this fight a bit
Danish watching walked in the vid sees
affluent Paulo Costa you all Romero and
I bet nobody went why he went and then
just walked away yeah hey do us a favor
but muscle that's muscle grab a cup of
coffee while we make this fight happens
with the most muscular guys to ever step
into a [ __ ] I also don't agree with
this matchup
I mean you will you know for Paul Acosta
is a young guy just had his first I kind
of major win super young Yoel coming off
the fight he just came off of you knows
a tough [ __ ] customer so you so right
away we have to find out if Paul kostos
the number three world you can't give
him a and he has everything he has to
look they could become a young phenom
with the comparisons to beat or bell for
oh we got one
here's your Romero yeah [ __ ] yeah you
looks just what the you're just lost the
title shot yeah some people thought he
wanted the UFC seems to eat its young
this new it's desperation its
desperation because they're starving for
stars because they're not make such
costo you know give stars time well even
if cos will beat you know your room out
it's still gonna take time to get them
into the super limelight oh and then
you're gonna toss them to [ __ ]
Whitaker
no but now Whitaker's out for a while
with hand surgery so you can't fight the
mid-late to a nineteen so they're just
they're starving for it mmm-hmm Wow and
then they announce Luke Rockhold Chris
Weidman and the F Kevin Kelvin Gastelum
fighting
why are they doing Luke Rockhold mom I
didn't hear that one
Weidman again why are they doing that
again - you know I
the the Luke Rockhold fight with Gus
Finn isn't happening guess you know Luke
rot Luke got hurt and then Weidman rock
will make sense to me last time they
fought you know it was a good fight
until Weidman [ __ ] through that weird
spinning back-kick heel kick and they
got ate the [ __ ] up it's not a bad
fight it's not about final and they're
both two and three kind of makes it way
more clear like still congested in there
there's not a lot of clarity makes sense
what else you get chin this one's not
really a current event much but I just
thought it was cool Paige Vanzant posted
recently know that she's a little
different I'm John oh she's just no no
she did I know she even announced it how
it's awesome she looks at me yeah he
looks amazing by far the best fight of
ever came out of the you see looking by
far Oh for me and by the way I got
Valentina Shiv Shankar I think she's hot
as [ __ ] really personally and the other
pole hey girl just Janko over that
yes sir you've lost all credibility yes
he ever hurt being lip get the [ __ ] out
give me bring up Franco right yeah
compares are hers
compared to her yeah Jesus Christ you
know even that we're not even same rare
volunteer Shanker oh my god you could
she mmm
be nice there's a reason why you like
her you also love CrossFit which one you
want to see well you know one on the
right there's this one but also you like
dudes she's beautiful that's a good
picture hot
listen go go please hit the arrow please
oh there oh yeah herim page fans all
right on
[ __ ] you have a kados look at her now I
know you've gone please keep going I
made a study of this telling you right
now Valentina Shevchenko is a hot no
that's not gonna worry let's just go
look at yeah you don't click do like
that
I like this one sure there we go
she's a sexy girl man yeah chins with me
on the food
no but you also like CrossFit dude so
this man like an athletic one yeah
compare her to Paige Vanzant I mean
they're all they're all beautiful in
their own right yeah me see I got me
should take number one each of them with
you on page as old is that girl off
tough who's ridiculously and she looks
like a supermodel okay yeah oh they I
agree I think is she wine you know what
I'm a stranger ostrich dude right what
are we doing how does she not have a
modeling career she's alright she could
be a ring-card girl let me see she's all
right you know I you know you don't have
enough muscle for brawn she's clearly
gave it account that's probably
different account no it was her no that
wasn't another fake count
I'm sure if you does search it you can
find it I'll just search it she's a
freaking smoke show what about that what
about the the other Polish girl there we
go
who's really pretty oh dude you remember
talked about you wanna [ __ ] him Oh
snowman you're not in this conversation
look at that oh no no Bo go back that
way she's go back to that one she must
be Russia's prettier than all the ring
card girls jeez what are we talking
about
she's bodied up too deep Shevchenko the
out of my [ __ ] Studios look at her
bring up the other polish girl she looks
like the card - Rose namajunas I got
rose over page I got ya get out
I got rose over serve as a shaped head
this all makes sense on why exactly did
you give your game your big game and I
like oh no dude baby I mean I like I
like wow that girl is something else
though are you kidding me
it's your fighter yeah I'm not mad at
that then there's some tournament I was
really talking about well we're talking
about what was the post on page though
what the hell just just just fat ass
titties yeah that's it yeah it's kind of
old doctor no but that's first time I
saw an actual no she posted one was like
yeah
you haven't seen the golden 'scrimish
what's one follow yeah I do follow him
bet you do playboy she's beautiful but
this is a really I you know I don't see
a long UFC career for now no but she's
partly she's doing exactly she should be
doing
she's partly into something good her man
made it to the UFC I think you want on
the contender series adorable but when
you get breast implants as a fighter you
got to realize like that's probably
right like you know like that's not
gonna benefit matter as far as like it
let's take it hard to fight my way right
isn't it I mean I don't know you can't
be an advantage right well Miesha Tate
let me stay pulls the muffins very well
yes she does yes she does she's a couple
fighters are better looking the ring
card girls yeah who's that one that's
Misha she's had a beige he looks really
good yeah me she's hot as [ __ ] to me
who's that guy John Shelby matchmaker
great dude she had a baby with who
someone that was on tough when she was
idols just use coaching yeah damn good
for him wow this is an awesome picture
clear what else yet gin alright there's
this a waitress in Georgia who was
getting groped by a guy the guy just
walked by and touched her ass and she's
basically body slammed into the ground
damn like Undertaker's down you'll see
right here it's a good slam to so she's
just going to the cash register and the
guy walks by just cops of feel boom look
how she grabs him but he falls down
drunk anyways yeah he was arrested hmm
give her a little finger tap what was
her message oh that don't dad don't let
people do that to you and then she
didn't realize her own strength when she
did that I mean she can just I would I
would say it was a body slam would you
Brian you you push to be tossed him
against the wall having to take a seat I
mean she didn't lift under take bodies
don't
they don't put my lambo you pushed him
down he's hammered and trip yeah still
tied job I was such a lame he was like
he was like this sorry
let's shoot my shot I'm a bad boy what
if he's like punish me girl yeah bump my
balls over and over again
your substances acidosis videos guys
just King King how did they not puke I
don't know man they get into we're
seeing those videos chin which was
typing girl kicks man in balls we just
to stay there these videos where guys
get off on gay like your ass kicked I
feel like there be a thing you like chin
that's not non YouTube chin non YouTube
we're just regular sites yeah I hate
doing this thing I feel like you'd be
something you might be into chin like if
someone's like do you not seen [ __ ]
kick the balls by those girls
hell no yeah girl kicks man balls it's
on YouTube no I'm looking like it's kind
of if you catch my drift
go there dude market they might want to
go to like actual more actual porn like
redtube you know you know how it goes
now to go to the warren hub please do
that yeah I mean pick your boys in tin
it looks like this second site gets like
really let's drag off together fellas I
look fat guys there you go one see that
one top left dominatrix kicking balls go
down there
well people you'll see this gym yeah
yeah for sure well there you go she's
got a Lynch what first of all fall
busting universe and he's happy he's
covered in a [ __ ] dude this is
actually someone's [ __ ] like people lipo
are into getting their bragging
keep gone go keep fast forward I don't
want to see this guy's we're dawn there
was about limped off yeah they're never
hard dude do you know bad this would
hurt that looks for that stuff and then
he spreads his legs really serious with
high heels dude and he likes it that was
nice
oh yeah what no she's Charlie browning
his dick right now that hurts dude she's
kicking him right in his nuts oh that
would hurt
she's not going full go there girl in
the back with getaway ardor not like
I've seen I've seen people sweat off on
them J right they stomp on their necks
like their ah
cuppa take sweet yeah I gotta see Jana G
and Jenna no see this white this yeah
she's actually kicking him dude Brian
would if someone paid you I don't know
10 grand would you do this no dude
Oh to do it to a dude yeah 10 grand I
give it to charity
I would do it right I'm like dude take
you 1 X free I'm gonna kick you once
Crow cops down and that's to me the end
of this video bro oh that's poor guy but
no he's Brian he signed up for this he's
getting paid for them guess he is yeah
you know he likes that he gets off on
this all right
is that good enough yeah it is it is I'm
done yeah I don't feel well after all
look at this crime huge bar I can
explain you guys no I can explain
huh dude that [ __ ] there are lots of it
apparently there's this psychology
behind it where people that are into
that apparently they were like they
could have been masturbating when they
were kids and they got hurt like
somebody threw a ball at their head
while they were doing it and they they
can they cross the signals I don't know
what the [ __ ]
speaking of balls or close to balls you
guys have to talk about the Conor
McGregor sure last time you got kicked
in the nuts I've never been kicked in
the nuts ever in your life know who the
hell kicked me in the nuts life bro five
chicken that's broke you're gonna get
kicked and that's a kitten and that's by
like a baseball anything else plan when
you play football never wear a cup man
are you in Miami this guy this gentleman
stomp on my nuts with his cleat oh right
like he was like [ __ ] you white boy
really wish to the dig really I was like
well okay prison rules on boys wow they
beat us did you get him back sure didn't
because I'm not that type of dude no I'm
looking like you know I must seek out
that giant you got I would see a guy of
a guy [ __ ] with you like that did you
did you ever settle scores that way
I mean I got a penalty because I late
hit him on the next play okay not the
same he won this battle
we got penalized 15 yards and my nuts
[ __ ] hurt man that hurts I never take
the nut chin I want to kick in the know
I want life to kick in the night a good
nut kicking no no thank you you gotta
get stuck or squeeze that's a tug Conor
Sarah Connor is not happy with this
pointer yeah so fun is a balls this is
that big dick energy kind of over the
top though you know like you're for you
to post a picture I get ya rub that
thing up I get but this kind of that
game thing where like dudes go come on
bro and girls you know I'm sure is dm's
are insane but I'm not that impressed
with his daughter I was gonna say like
if you're gonna post some we're gonna
post on with that you should you look
skinny though looks a little yeah it
just it's kind of pointing to the side
I'm not that impressed you still long
though but the long I think we you and I
do just fine in that area I don't for
sure thank you and I would have any
problem matching that you know he's
basically as opponent in that dummy
that's another hard like it's not like
this job and then so scale one to 10
that's a seven right yah you for yeah
yeah do for people are like wait is the
aroused there's that just a fat dick
hanging out I just see a pointing I'm
just not that impressed thank you and
let's just call it up you don't say like
it's like
lit up like a cobra so just don't do
that with your dick anyway and also I
don't mean what are you doing with the
selfie posting that it's for as fast
program is called a virus kind of
McGregor fast I don't know it's funny to
me look how many likes it has though
like it he's doing to get attention that
and it worked in it yeah kind of a lot
of likes me
marketing 101 gentleman what else you
got guardians of the galaxy director
being fired after some like ten-year-old
tweets that he made long time ago right
yeah 10 years were they bad though
that's the thing did you see his
response he goes I want to apologize for
tweets I made 10 years ago he said he
won't know he goes in I want apologizing
emphasized goes for tweets that I made
10 years ago that have affected my
career today he said he was but he won't
always wanted to be push the envelope
and be comical but so what is this but
what exactly they say here's a bunch of
his tweets aggregated so a lot of them
are about like little like pedophilia
type of things
see like jokes around I got a little bit
of a red flag here because I don't know
I I know some funny people no one jokes
about yeah you know I'm saying what was
different even like here no no no no
back then today 30 years ago no jokes
about little boys but this may have been
taken out of context me at my silly
place he might have been talking about
yeah I don't know what he's talking
about here yeah so that's thing they're
all out of context but even looking at
these posts like the Expendables The
Expendables are so manly I [ __ ] the
[ __ ] other little [ __ ] boy next to me
the boys are back in town see I have a
problem with Eagle snatches kid is what
I call or rather is what I call it when
I get lucky and then he put three men
and a baby they had sex with yeah it's
all little boys thank you yes working
I'm doing a big Hollywood film adaption
of the giving tree with a happy ending
the tree grows back and gives the kid a
blow job about to vomit as I'm stuff
with sue souffle and eggplant I'm Louie
a nursing my ass out just the fat not
the little boys there's a problem you
don't say like a reoccurring little boy
theme but hey it's not funny be I don't
I don't listen I don't know if she lost
his job I don't know enough about the
situation it's
I'm [ __ ] weird though man leave so
insoles are my first NAMBLA meeting
which is North American man-boy love
Association yeah it was the first time I
felt okay being Who I am
some of those guys are still my best
friends so he's being he's trying to be
funny about that and I put it put the
reoccurring theme all the little boy's
gun to my head so that Brendon that is
he does he have some sexual interest in
little boys I'd say yes get in my head
to Thea he's got a ton of people like a
ton of fans backing him up too cuz he's
you know obviously everyone loves that
movie without franchise yeah I don't
know man that's [ __ ] tricky he have
his ten years ago his career like that's
the big thing now so he's lost guarding
the galaxies yeah I don't know what
happens he's like [ __ ] I started fun and
he's being silly and funny out so you're
saying he was just trying to push the
envelope of being funny and nowadays you
I don't know anyone who tries to be
funny like that little weird boys can
you imagine if we kept this let's say
you and I are hanging out the first hour
hang up and I kept making little boy
jokes bye dude well [ __ ] I don't think
that's a problem I'd like I'm just
joking like I don't think it's funny I
never have know that I'd go back you're
like dude something's [ __ ] wrong with
Brian akyuu something a little boys yeah
I don't like that no one does I get
tight-lipped about who's funny jokes
about this you know I'm saying only I
know no [ __ ] it's not over and over
it's uncomfortable yeah
it's poor taste shitty of long living
we're living in a time where what you
said any time in your life can ruin your
career and I don't think it makes the
world more equitable and I don't think
it makes the world a better place but
that's the reality punishment over
change we're more interested in
punishment and a lot of people are
trying to punish because they think it
can change the world and make it better
it doesn't but yeah in some cases it
might the guy that got this exposed his
name is Michael Stern ovitch he's the
one that was pushing pizza gate a long
time ago
yikes even he after he got this exposed
and got him fired they're looking at his
old tweets and they're seeing stuff that
he's done and said that are not cool
something about rain you imagine being
that type of imagine this imagine your
life is like Oh any people hopefully I
can get the guy who directed garden
he fired by looking his old tweets well
these guys tonight then I accumulate all
that [ __ ] and then push out imagine that
guy sent home at night like anybody is
that conspiracy [ __ ] yeah everything
there's this idea that Hollywood and the
Democratic Party have these pedophile
rings and child slavery and child
cannibal rings have you read this this
is all this stuff on that so this is
this this this thing that no you middle
point be I'm saying imagine being the
person I know that's responsible imagine
going home tonight and feel like dude
they're in hold on structure you put all
that time and effort and you get this
man fired
well I'm sorry what's it do for you
justice justice how though yeah think of
think just I take a second she's not
weird how big of a loser you have to be
whether you dedicate a negative youtube
page comment a forum you bring up old
info on old celebrities like think about
that guy's life yeah and if you're one
of those guys listen this there's not a
woman on this planet that wants to [ __ ]
you it does sure they don't go hand in
hand
yeah it just doesn't work like that you
don't gain any you don't gain any
notoriety you win no awards no girl
thinks you're hotter the none of that
comes with this it's such a weird world
it is a weird world that's crazy to me I
don't know what else you do this one
here 50 cent and Floyd Mayweather
Mayweather out of the blue posted a huge
long thing about 50 cent talking smack
on about dude well they used to be best
friends right these to be but they see
very close I'm not sure how it started
capped off it has to with a girl uh I
don't think so originally but that
that's where it went
no no this I think it started here work
you know how Floyd's entourage got shot
at recently Drago I think he thinks 50s
responsible somehow yeah and then they
started I think that's the rumor I'm not
and then I got it's starting a super
night what do you like crazy so long
though this do you do long he's talking
about his son doesn't want to be with
them and how he's poor and he's a crappy
mansion it's just a like a money trap
and then 50 cent went back at hand
Herbies to know that 50 cent went back
at him with this him crying and he talks
about his eleven domestic violence cases
and then he goes on to say this is a
post he made about Floyd's pretend rough
draft of how he was supposed to write
250 and you just you know obviously
misspelled everything anyways it's very
public I'm not sure what's going on and
there's a six line how can I enter this
beef you think I got a structure talking
about I got herpes he's a walking bag or
STDs lol so he goes how can I enter this
beef that's all Harris who is this that
crazy not crazy but that wild dude with
all the tattoos on his face is rainbow
hair what is a core [ __ ] I'm a 50 cent
tries anything in stay relevant
what is she alright let's look at this
real quick not too long ago we did this
current event with Josh hater yeah
after he found out the old tweets and he
was like anti-gay and anti
black or whatever 16 or 17 yeah 17 years
old so the first time he took the mound
afterwards after all that came out he
got a huge standing ovation from the
fans what stay was this Milwaukee
Milwaukee yeah America hold on let's see
uh
I'm fight a country for sure Miller Park
where's Miller party there's no
Milwaukee yeah it's Milwaukee yeah there
you go is it possible that they were
just trying to give them support wait I
mean it's still interesting I think
now there's one thing about support in
the celebration guys but see that it's
all standing up of course they're gonna
support but it's just an odd timing a
weird at least there's a lot of
minorities in the craft it's all is that
a trump convention I mean he's a kid
what's his baseball career listen I
don't agree with in it I've never been
raised to understand out racist tweets
under than any of that but he shouldn't
lose his professional career comes down
to this for me I never wanted to hurt
anybody's feelings like even with my
stand-up I never have ever like said
jokes that were derogatory of a group
cuz I don't want to I never said
anti-gay stuff even when it was accepted
in the nineties where I was doing
Stanton when when you could say anything
you wanted you could make fun of black
do we do it I just imagine I'm screwed
if it that when you were 14 or 15 16
year old if we had Twitter oh I know I
promise you you would not look at
Michael Jordan the things you learn more
you just [ __ ] all of us were [ __ ] it
was cool is [ __ ] terrible was into if
I said things when I was 40 and now I'm
50 and I'm like why but I was younger
and now or like all right dude what else
you get Jim all right this is a
controversial one so there's a
stand-your-ground law yeah in Florida
this is [ __ ] up but you can yeah you
can defend yourself by actually shooting
someone and then so this particular
person and you can see him right here
he's I guess he doesn't all dude that
hangs around this market and he watches
for people parking handy got the
handicapped spots he's gonna make and
then he gets in Martinez with them right
well the man that he shoots and kills
his wife and kids watched him die yeah
so they were in the car they parked in
the handicapped spot what she shouldn't
do but while he runs in yeah well he's
how many of us have done that yeah yeah
so here guilty in front of his wife and
kid he pushes this guy down he pushes
him too which is a bad push as well so
just pushes off that bad the pushes like
that [ __ ] waitress when the guys
slaps her ass no this is watch check
this up
I mean I don't like this like no one is
good at bruh damn you shouldn't shoot
for this reason I don't think but who
knows this guys that you start hunch it
to his wife and kids so watch this so he
pushes him to the ground at this point
he's not attacking him and then he
shoots him ran in the heart now he dies
inside the market no so you can you can
see that the guy wasn't going at him
right when they got pulled a gun he just
he was there and they get shot him no
that's because of this law for that [ __ ]
you know you don't you didn't go to jail
he didn't get arrested however the
legislators over there are pushing for
him to get arrested so it's a very
controversial law
demi lovato you sure I'll have that up
somewhere but I'll just click on this
one so you know demi lovato overdose
chief so freaking hot to me yeah so she
relapsed apparently she relapsed not too
long ago before I she talked about it
and she she had a song she's had a bad
problem then stomach she's done
interviews you know I've seen on cocaine
all mm old prom and she Odie's they
think it was meth and heroin yeah they
said they think it could be Matt Hardy
or heroin but then they use a drug
called mark n a narc on to do Reviver
and I guess if it was meth you don't use
that drugs she's yeah cocaine over the
holidays and then she's doing a concert
and forgot the lyrics she's all [ __ ]
up forgot the lyrics that's when you
know you're in trouble
oh so she had a she has a history of
drug use yeah but she did she's awake
and conscious and all that stuff right
now so she's talked about she suffers
from bipolar and depression and eating
disorder like she's got a ton of stuff
checking sauce I'm so depressed about
that poor guy raikou i know it's like no
yeah what else you got chin I mean these
are they're all sad pants ones what do
you think of this so well this isn't
right now the guy got fired with so an
uber driver would live stream videos in
his car with people inside that don't
know it no that's right yeah they don't
agree to it yeah I'm
I'm assuming I'm not being videotaped to
the world no I'm saying stuff to Brian
I'm saying why I'm sure about our
business
yeah my personal stuff maybe [ __ ] that
guy yeah there's no over and lift I
think either they encourage or they say
you should have a video camera just in
case something bad happen livestream on
social media exactly and that's also not
being uploaded so burglar like everyone
can see yeah that's safe for them in
case there's an accident or there's a
theft going on are gray uh what else you
got let's go look through these a fan
yelled as Tiger Woods took a swing you
know how to say [ __ ] during golf then
you change that and we go happy gilmore
son come on let me ride you but I didn't
really mess him up Tiger swing he's
looking over to the left your Tigers not
happy though no he's pissed off
and everyone's booing the guy that yells
used to be so there's no there's no ruin
alright there's no rule well it's like
bass while there's hidden rules you
don't say [ __ ] turn the back sir off in
your [ __ ] life here knows that said
it's gin
one more please please don't be someone
dying no Buffy the Vampire Slayer Joss
Whedon who was the creator of it he's
gonna do a reboot with a black female
lead which is interesting so so there's
a scale things that come in too and give
a [ __ ] about and so 10 would be your
Rimmel Paula coast oh that's cool man
Buffy the Vampire Slayer would be like a
[ __ ] one chin was that where you're
going with this there is an interesting
thing that's a black Lee there's a lot
of press see boom pressure on all the
networks to really color create a lot of
put a lot of color in mm-hmm
that was the topic that we're looking at
I don't give a cool man I don't view the
world in colors you know I'm saying yeah
man cool you booked up you mean you
picked a good actress and she happens to
be black yeah for the key bleed of Buffy
cool little twist all right but that's
it that's okay sir
yes hey buddy you gotta use that Lib
tinker bro shut up it's fine it's good
to come back together
you happy you're back yeah Ellie Doug
we're gonna do rugged aren't we you
almost said Logan let's go to Rogen and
we'll die I'm gonna grab a bite to eat I
might have to stop by my house real
quick just up at the crib you know you
have time to eat and stop the house okay
I'm gonna see some around here then all
right dude gentlemen thank you for
listening to us I'm gonna win oh yeah my
dates man I'm not giving up on stand up
oh yeah I forgot about yeah I don't I
got
Austin first week of August cap city
Thursday Friday Saturday say can we come
in Dallas I'll be taking the JFK towards
somewhere Dallas Houston improv second
week of August then this just they just
want on sale Justin out September 13th
one night out of the
Theatre in Vancouver one night September
13th those sales just those tickets just
went on sale t fat K calm for everything
you need I think that's it be that's it
buddy this sapphire kid we're out